we won't get. Okay, here we go. So, another Zoom call, we have a bunch of questions that got sent in.
So, we're going to get to those first and then you can chat in whatever questions you want
anytime you want. Remember, always have questions between these Zoom calls to go to our website and look at
uh, ethanol, a little, a magnified glass and you can, and uh, search for something. You have almost
a thousand pages on our website with information. So, you may find it already there. Hopefully,
everybody's on the membership site. I know some people have sent in questions to me via email.
Well, please do that on the membership site. There's a spot under all the pages that you can ask
that you can submit your Zoom call questions. And some of you are emailing you're in the A's on
those questions. Please use the membership site for that if you can. It's the best way not to get
a question missed. We also have announcements on there. If you haven't been on the membership site,
you haven't seen that we're added a Zoom call. Mondays at noon with Ann. So, take advantage of that.
Ann is doing the Zoom call Mondays at noon. So, she'll be answering questions as well. And that's
place where you can jump on. Same feel as this, but it'll be Ann doing those.
All right. Here's some questions with a ladder cancer with small chunks of tissue becoming out
with her urine. This is the person talking about her mother's ladder cancer. If the rife attack on
the tumors is working. Yes, that can be true. That can be true with other cancers too. We've had people
with colon cancers or rectal cancers where they start using the rife, start using the nutritional
protocol. So, I don't know if it's the right for their supplements or what's doing it. But the tumors
died and pieces are falling off. And you could be passing them in your stool or you could be passing them
in a year. I can't say with certainty that that's exactly what's happening could be something else. So,
I don't know, but yes, we have seen that happen. She hasn't been able to eat well for some time. So,
has not been taken to supplements for about three weeks, but I've been ready to overnight sessions
twice per day and now a lot of looking trash chunks are being expelled. So, let's pray that that is
what's happening with the cancer has been killed by her immune system. That's what we want to be doing.
Is it okay to use the P4 LPEMF machine following tumor embolization and insertion of a plate
and screws into the humorous due to a pathological fracture? Yes. So, the P-E-M-F is not going to
interfere with any metallic inserted device in your body. The P-E-M-F will interfere if you have
a defibrillator. So, if you have something that's an electronic device, that's a totally different
thing. When a metal plate screws in your leg, ready to like that is no. You can still use the P-E-M-F
with that. It's only a defibrillator that you have to be concerned about with P-E-M-S. How are you
familiar with quantum physics? A little bit, especially with the A-O scan instead of a PET scan.
So, I think the A-O scan is, sometimes I don't look at these questions before I'm answering them.
I do apologize. I believe the A-O scan is like the Zyto scan? Yes, that's what it is.
So, that is, you're not comparing apples to apples here. The PET scan is completely different than
an A-O scan or a Zyto scan. It's completely different. There's benefits to Zyto scan. There's benefits
to the A-O scans. There's numerous different types of frequency type scans like that on the market
that practitioners can use. There's some benefit to them. I would be very careful,
diagnosed. Off of those, some practitioners take that to the nth degree. Because of, let's say,
bacterial frequency, you have to hit on a bacterial frequency on one of those scans,
then they say that you have that bacterial infection. That is not true. So, there's this use of
any device you have to be careful with that. It means that you had to hit on that frequency. Maybe
that frequency would be good for you, but it does not mean you have that disease. It certainly is not
a substitute for a PET scan. I mean, it's like saying, you know, is, you know, should I drive a car
to work or should I eat apples? We're talking about two different components, things here. That's
how different these two things are. So, it's certainly not a substitute for PET scan.
Question that came in before I answer this one. Does the hammer bulb have to be next to the
skin? Will it work through clothing? No, it will work through clothing. It doesn't need to have a
skinned skin contact. It will go through clothing. But we do have some people that say, is it all right?
If I'm using the hammer bulb, if it's three feet away from me. So, remember, in the farther you move
any of the bulbs that you're using with the right away from you, the least the lesser impact it's
going to have on your body. So, the closer it is to the body, the better impact it's going to have
on your body. So, you do want to have it as close to you as possible. Clothing really doesn't make
any difference. It will go through clothes just fine. This question on the slide, are you familiar
with light vantage products, especially in the there are two products? Wouldn't this be good for
breast cancer? I'm not familiar with the light vantage products on top of the head, if I look
that off the nerve two products should be fine. The nerve two pathway is basically stimulated with
two reference of the flabinoids. That's probably what's in that product. Most of the nerve two
products that are out there have those in there. This should be fine. Before I start out, your program
is put out a keto diet and lost lots of weight. I'm just copying the pace of these from your
things here. So, 5, 7, and right now I weigh about 13 cubs. That's pretty teedy for 5 foot 7. I also have
low thyroid. So, low thyroid will typically cause a person to have difficulty losing weight.
I am struggling to put weight back on right now. Can you help me with that? It also can help me
regulate my thyroid. So, if you're struggling putting weight back on, it can be due to the diet
that you're on. It can be due to that you have your, you're, you're diagnosed with hypothyroid,
and you're taking too much of its replacement, whether you're on synthetic thyroid, or whether
you're on a natural substance, you can take too much of it and you will end up putting your
state in a, your thyroid in a state of relative hyperthyroid, and you will lose weight and have
a difficulty putting weight on. You can have difficulty putting weight on because of the cancer,
and then there's some sets to that maybe because of the cancer and it's causing you to have some
nauseousness or inability to want to eat and you're not eating it up calories or because of the cancer
and you have anemia. And the anemia is because it's called anemia product disease when you have anemia,
low, people go with low red blood cell and it's because the cancer may be feeding off of iron.
So there's multiple factors that could be going on and we need to dig into this a little bit.
My doctor doesn't seem to understand any more than the normal blood tests by genetic tests as a
back eater. The genetic tests won't really tell us why a person's not able to gain weight,
so really we should have a clone cell to talk about this a little bit deeper. So we may want to do a
better thyroid test or look at the thyroid test that you may have had so we can investigate that
and investigate your current diet, whether keto is right for you or not.
Keto, if you're out of keto, keto like diet at this point in time, you will lose a lot of weight,
typically that's a diet that people will choose to lose weight because you're basically
starving your body of carbohydrates, trying to get it yourself into a state of what's called ketosis
where your body's feeding off of ketones, which can be good for certain cancers, especially brain
cancers, but not necessarily for every cancer because most people have a ketogenic diet that are
either more protein or more dairy and dairy is not good for most other cancers, so we need to make
sure that we're discussing this. At times, the skin on my breast is thicker than others.
Yes, that can be, I think you're talking about spaker than other times,
so that can be true if there's a relative state of inflammation there, which is good, which
was what we're trying to do, so we're trying to cause a relative state of inflammation at different
times and it's better and surges like that because what is inflammation, but it is in a muted response
to the area, so that's what we're trying to do, so that I would say is a good thing.
Can circulated tumor cells be zero via blood tests, but a tumor marker be increasing the answers.
Yes, so you can have circulated tumor cells at a state of zero, made it a dual blood test for
circulated tumor cells, so there's no circulated tumor cells seed in that
blood that was taken out of your artery. Well, that's a great thing, but it really does it, that's
what I don't recommend people do circulate tumor cell tests because it's not how much circulating
tumor cells you have at this point in time circulating in your blood, it's how it's, at some point in time
that you had cancer, some point in time that this cancer was growing in you, possibly even pre-diagnosis
of cancer, you had circulated tumor cells and it's not the circulated tumor cells in our blood that
is a concern, it's the circulated tumor cells in the tissue that are still considered
circulated tumor cells or maybe a better term as cancer stem cells that maybe are not in a state
of rapid replication yet. That's what we're concerned about and that's not measured, there's no way
to measure that, so to me, I don't see value in doing a circulated tumor cell blood test because it
could give us an idea of oh look I have a zero circulated tumor cell so I'm really doing really
well, it doesn't need that at all, that means you have zero circulated tumor cells in that you know
so many milliliters of blood that was drawn out of you, so that doesn't tell you where the tissues
at, but you may have circulated tumor cells 18 months ago that are still dormant in the tissues,
we don't, it doesn't tell us any of that, CEA increase or any tumor marker increase has to do with
an increase, possible increase of growth in the cancer, just a slight increase might be nothing
like any other test you have to balance that with other tests and side symptoms as well, so
CEA or any other tumor marker spike more highly suggests that the tumor is growing that could be
from the primary tumor not from secondary tumor, so there's too many factors going on there,
how long can one use IP6, so IP6 is a nutrient that can be good to help your body kill cancer,
it could be a key later as well, I've taken 32 hundred milligrams a of a PM,
can this affect my old iron, so that's a good thought process there, so can take a key later like
IP6 actually decrease my iron level by maybe key lading iron out of my body, that's possible, yes
that is possible, you know, so I like the way this person is thinking because that is a possibility and
it's something that they want to investigate, and one of the things you can do is just kind of go
on a trial, I'm going to drop IP6 completely for two weeks and retest my iron, because my air go up
a little bit after that's two weeks because your body is going to produce iron during that time and
you might bump it up a little bit that could be a good experiment, to clarify the no white potatoes
guidance in her prescribed diet from Dr. Cutters, we're wondering if she can still have red potatoes,
gold potatoes or purple potatoes, can you help with that please, so when we're asking a person to
limit their white potatoes, the reason why is that potatoes have a higher glycemic index than
even table sugar does, so we need you will break down potatoes into glucose
even quicker than your brachydone sucrose, which is a dye saccharide into glucose, which is a
model saccharide, so glucose, which is a model saccharide, it's just one ring or get it chemistry-wise,
then is glucose is what goes into the cycle of your body breaking down into produce ATP,
which then produces two coqueous molecules and which can then convert to lactic acid, which
then can then be a feeder of cancer, so that's the idea of glucose sugar, but eat a feeder of
cancer when we say that sugar, I mean we're using that term grossly because sugar incorporates
any saccharide molecule like sucrose or glucose or galactose or fructose, these are all sugars,
so more complex sugars, okay, carbohydrates that are found in white potatoes, some ironically could
break down to glucose faster than even a dye saccharide like sucrose, so when we say to a person
we're trying that may their cancer may be feed off of glucose and the breakdown of glucose to
lactic acid, we say limit your white potatoes it's because of that, now to get specific to the question
red potatoes, gold potatoes, purple potatoes, pig potatoes, green potatoes are all fitting into the
white potato category, so the only thing that doesn't fit into the white potato category for you that
are still called potatoes are your yams or sweet potatoes, oh I know those are two different things,
but both yams and sweet potatoes are technically not potatoes, they are in a different class and they
don't have the same glycemic index, meaning they don't break down to glucose like potatoes do,
so any potatoes, so when we say white potatoes, maybe we need to clarify that a little better in that
form, we're talking about red potatoes, you call gold potatoes or any potatoes, so to show I shouldn't,
been more prepared to the picture of a potato patch this year because I am,
and my wife and I are avid gardeners, we do have to make some videos of our garden, we have a lot of
raised beds that I build, and I went nutsle this winter, I built 19 new raised beds, and we grew a
big patch of potatoes that are raised beds last year, and when you're raised bedguarded potatoes
you take them along space, so I just dedicated one raised bed to potatoes last year, and it was
just so much fun, we ate them all so fast, we didn't even get to store any for the winter that I
made another, put another bedded to a raised bedded potatoes this year, and I actually bought myself
for my birthday, a rototiller for my bobcat, so we live out of 20 acres, and I've had a bobcat
since we moved there, and a rototiller for my bobcat sparked me to, okay my wife thinks I'm addicted
to this now, but I killed up this giant bedded planted five rows of, about 54 rows of potatoes,
I don't want to do 600 pounds of potatoes, but if anybody needs potatoes, you just come over to my
house because we're going to have to put up a roadside stand, at the end of our driveway, give it a
way, vegetable selling, we have somebody's zucchini right now, I don't know what to do with it, we just
throw them all in the cobblers, but it's fun growing things, I love growing potatoes,
and potatoes are great, but they have a high glyceric index unfortunately, and they break down the
sugar quite quickly, but they're fun to grow. All right, that's it for the questions I kind of
moved through those today, so any other questions you need to chat in now is the time to do that,
do the questions go to both Monday and Wednesday calls from the site, yes they do, so
if your questions, if you have questions that you specifically want me to answer, then just
mark that, we didn't create a separate question box for the Monday call from Anne, but she does
say, you know she does tell me that hey, not sure if I answered this question right, or at least she
said she will, she hasn't had to do that, yeah, could you answer this other call on Wednesday, but she
will do that, she's very knowledgeable, but she's also very humble, and she won't try to answer
something she doesn't know to answer for it. If you want some of what are your questions that you put
in the question spot of the of the of the member site, then you want specifically for Anne to
answer, then just say Anne, then answer the question, you want it specifically for me to answer,
then say Dr. C, then ask your question, so that she'll just push it to me or I'll just push it to her.
Her calls, hers and calls are also recorded, and you'll see them on the site as well, so they're
already up there. Any tips on how to grow broccoli sprouts, oh that's a good question, I don't have any
tips on that, we grew sprouts years ago, but it's been a lot of times since we've grown sprouts,
I would, that's a good, YouTube question, there's people that that's all they do, so I don't know that,
sorry, I've been ademic for a while now, today my doctor suggested starting an iron supplement,
do you want me to send a cheek swab to you and wait for your recommendations, send me the lands first,
I want to see if that's what we should do, and we'll go off of that first. That is always a catch
22, we talked about that a couple weeks ago, first it has anemia with low iron, and it's quite possible
that the cancer is feeding off of iron, and we give it iron to deal with the anemia, so you start
taking the iron supplement and you're basically feeding the cancer, yeah, it's really difficult,
that may be true, so sometimes it's better to not use iron if the anemia quote unquote diagnosis
on the blood test is showing a more in a more mild state, it might be better to use food-based things
to help build that up without directly giving it iron, meaty like beets, beetroot, beetroot powder,
liver, spleen supplements, things like that instead of giving iron, it's also with anything,
I think we talked about this last week or the week four as well with anything, we have a blood test
showing low iron, low people globin, you always want to ask the question why, why isn't low, is it because
I have a deficiency in iron, that can be true with some people, but most likely it's not true with
you, it's more likely true that you know the first thing you want to ask is why with anemia is there
a loss of blood somewhere, or are you bleeding somewhere, so you want to investigate that,
the person has a diagnosis of cancer, okay, is the cancer gobbled up to iron, is that what's
taking place, the other thing with a low hemoglobin and low red blood cells, you do want to look at
B12 issues, that could be a possibility, especially if it's a denial category, so those things you
want to look at, so let's see the blood work first, can we just pop on the on either zoom then
absolutely, yep, yep, so you can, that's what these are for, so these are for you, this is a
new zoom call, with and on Mondays, you can jump on both zoom calls, you can do it every day here,
you so desire to have every every week, you jump on ads and up on my, you can ask us the same
questions if you get a different answer, no, I'm just kidding, don't ask, don't do that, but that's what
these are for, just for you to get more help, we're moving more and more towards the zoom type
platform and set a one-on-one calls for a couple reasons, number one, it saves you money by you asking
questions over the zoom, oh this is a real intimate question, I don't want to ask an intimate question,
well that's why you, you said it on the member site, you said the question in because then
you know your name isn't on there, I know people could see your names and such, sometimes on these
on the chance, but um so send it in anonymously, it'll always be an
anonymous if you send it into the member site, um and um secondly we're trying to move towards zoom
because from a medical legal standpoint, um we get harassed by state boards,
Minnesota State Board is attacking us right now, so um that's why we pulled all our testable,
our testimonial page off of our site because the Minnesota Board is, oh my gosh, this is horrible,
so that they, this is what we have to go through, so if we're doing everything out of zoom,
this is all educational, we're not performing telemedicine, so um they can't get at us,
so we have to keep ourselves protected, we don't want to keep doing it, we're doing it.
Uh okay question, I thought IP-6 removes iron from tumors, but it does not touch the iron that
is tightly bound, but he will go, well that is true, but I'm just saying that that's what the, what they,
you know the results of some studies have shown, but we just don't know if person has anemia,
also they're taking high doses of IP-6, it could be keylated, IP-6 works as a key later, so,
when we used to see years ago, they've seen a lot of non-cancer patients that had heavy metal toxicity
and different things, we used to use IP-6 a lot for keylaters, so it will keylate metals out of your
body, and it could keylate iron before it's bound to hemoglobin, so it can be keylating the
iron out, so it could end up being possibly a cause of anemia, and I didn't think about it until this
question was asked, that's why I said this is a great question, and that's why I love your questions,
because I learned from your questions, it could be a cause of anemia, that's a possibility,
using a keylate could be a cause of anemia, of course it would only be a mild anemia, it's not going to
cause a, you know, a more serious anemia, so still bleeding daily with bladder cancer, suspended
right for three weeks since having a go-like attack on the after ER visit and prednisone.
The is back to normal, should I go back to the right, yes, please go back to those and keep
posted for sure. On day 49 of my second round of Blacksap, yes, I got your email today, thank you
for that, I love the old pictures, this seems to take a long time, though I'm not, I'm thankful not
have to have to start the next round yet, any concerns about the length of time, no, no, no, not at all,
dealing with another patient with melanoma, and I think this is one of his last applications,
and it's just not coming out, it just seems to be dried up, and truthfully it may be healing
underneath, and it's just going to fall off, and you're going to see a lot of healing underneath,
that's quite, that's a strong possibility. Is it possible to begin Blacksap after chemotherapy
treatments, whether it's still residual disease? Yes, but remember, Blacksap, we're talking to a
topical Blacksap, isn't going to work unless you have cancer right near the surface,
so that's why Blacksap works so well on skin cancers, skin cancer technically is,
there still have layers of epithelial cells over the skin cancer,
but it will eat through a couple layers of cells, it's not going to eat through, you know,
down a centimeter or something like that, this is, it's just not going to pull the draw
that deep, so it has to be really, really close to the surface. The nice thing about you trying Blacksap,
if that's what you're trying to do is pull it out and draw it out, the nice thing is that if it doesn't
work, it just doesn't work, it's not going to hurt your skin. The bad thing that you have to be prepared
for if you're using Blacksap on a cancer that hasn't broken through the to the surface yet,
it's not necessarily a fun thing for the cancer to break through the surface, for some people it's
like, I just want to get it out, I don't care if it breaks through the surface, I don't care if I have
a wound, I don't care if I have to deal with dressing this thing on a daily basis, I want this out,
and I don't want to do surgery or mastectomy or whatever, I want this out, some people are like
gross, I can't handle this, it's going to get greasy, I'm going to get sick, well then using Blacksap
is not for that person, so you have to be mentally prepared for it as well, and that's a big thing,
you have to be mentally prepared for it, so typically with Blacksap done on a breast, there's not
a horrible amount of pain where you have to go get prescription pain beds, but you may have to take
Tylenol or adbilin or some pulmitic odor treatment, if you have a skin cancer of melanoma,
there could be a lot of pain, but I understand the pain is not the killing of the cancer, the pain
really isn't at the cancer itself, it's the stretching of the skin, so many times in melanoma,
they look like it's a centimeter around the skin and you put Blacksap on and starts eating it away,
it's really the size of a hard boiled egg underneath the skin and it's going to do a lot of
stretching as the skin pull it out and draw it out and it can hurt like the dickens and you may need
to be prepared with some medications. How long does it take for the video to be posted on the site?
I think I missed your answer to your question, so it should be posted right away, the only caveat to
that is sometimes I'm recording on Zoom and it's nothing that I'm doing, but Zoom messes up and then
all of a sudden the recording disappears to nowhere land, that's happened about three times so far
this year, so that's why I said, God willing, that spray that recording works otherwise just if it
doesn't work then let us know and I'll answer that again, so and then so look on the site and the
recordings are typically up just maybe 15 minutes after the Zoom close over. Any other questions?
If the mass is easily palpable, is that considered closer to this from the cell?
No, it has to literally be within a few millimeters of the surface, so it may be, the thing is you could
try and relax that if it's not going to draw, it's just not going to do anything, it's just going to
flake off and your skin might be a little bit red, a little bit irritated, but it didn't do anything,
you could try it again, so there's really a little hard to follow and try it, so some people will
use Black Sabbath, oh I don't know if this is a melanoma or it's a, or if it's just a boa,
they'll try it on the boa, and it just really won't do anything typically to a boa, it will really only
kill cancer or sound, so and I ask hand about my new short daily program to know
what I am working, I don't know what your question is but you are working, so your short daily
program is for your cancer, so there's a few people that I made specific daily programs for something
other than cancer that they are dealing with, some people have more than one diagnosis,
but don't think I did that for you off something yet, any danger in trying Black Sabbath
on a red spot on my temple area of my 72 year old father, yes, there is danger of using Black Sabbath
on your face, so think of what it did to your breast, but I don't need to say anymore, so you can get
scaried, so you just have to be careful, typically if it's a red spot it's not a melanoma,
so if it's a red spot, it's really common on people that as we age on our face are basal cell tumors,
so basal cell cancer is totally different, we don't need to use Black Sabbath on basal cell,
so basal cell cancers, I would try a different essential oils to begin with,
a regular oil tends to work well on basal cell multiple different oils do, so you can try
for weekends, you can alternate some different oils, also we created a curcumin tree that works really
well on basal cell tube, I would try that oils probably have a whole majority, I just put a drop
on your figure and put it on that spot, I would do those, I would do Black Sabbath,
it is really hard to keep my Black Sabbath dry between the summer heat, sweating, excessive
draining, bleeding, boy I know it is hard, well the Black Sabbath still work as well as it should be,
you may have to reapply a little bit if it just gets really wet and starts to fall off or something
like that, it seems I'm not losing as big a ask or as I expected, don't worry about that, you're
going to be reapplied, you're going to be getting it, so I would say just keep up, people get concerned
because they see a video on YouTube or something, it's like oh my it doesn't look like that, tell
you everybody's looks different, so don't worry about that, just keep just keep it up, okay I think
we'll end it for today then and we'll get this recording up as soon as possible, remember to
send in your questions on the members page for those who haven't and utilize those members pages
as best you can, all right thank you everybody, we'll be praying for you, please keep praying for us
and we will talk next week, make sure you get an anzum call as well and I just try to
read everybody's needs as best we possibly can, all right bye bye